for many people their their relationship
with their boss or could be anyone right
but this is safer for the sake of
argument your boss is seen as a major
source of stress in your life and what
can happen over time is that just
hearing your boss's voice or even
hearing the name of your boss or just
seeing your boss come walking down the
corridor induces tension right in our
body and in our mind and we feel my boss
is stressing me out as if my boss had
like this special power to induce stress
in me from his own side or her own side
but if that were the case if the boss
was actually a stress-induced sir then
you would just see everyone around the
boss getting stressed out this obviously
has to do with how you are perceiving
your boss in other words the stress
inducing boss has to do with your
perception of the boss so this is this
is interesting
basically you have created the stress
inducing boss now that is super
empowering to hear because that means
this is wonderful there's something I
can do about this if the boss was like
intrinsically you know a stress-induced
sir then what could you do but because
it's a it's a reflection of your own
mind the boss then becomes yeah like a
mirror reflecting back at you your own
uncontrolled states of mind and this
again is where meditation is very
important because it's important that we
cultivate an experience of inner
stillness in our heart in our heart so
that within that experience of stillness
we can actually think of our boss and
watch what comes up in our mind
so perhaps it'll be anger that'll come
up in our mind or perhaps it'll you'll
also discover that associated with that
is a strong sense of yourself as someone
who can't deal with your boss can't deal
with certain situation in other words
you're relating to yourself as being
someone inadequate or limited incapable
and the bosses is causing that sense of
limited that limited sense of self to
arise in your mind so we can discover in
other words what are the underlying
psychological states what are the
underlying states of mind that are
producing this rather unhappy
relationship and once once you see that
especially on the basis of that peaceful
still mind well then you can begin to do
something about it then you can go oh
because the the unattractive aspect of
my boss is arising due to my own anger
if I look if I start letting go of the
anger if I breathe it out and develop a
peaceful mind and then in meditation
begin to think what would be the better
response well for example I can think
about how my boss is helping me train my
mind
so rather than regarding your boss as
mr. or ms stress you can regard your
boss as your object of improving your
patience we all need such an object in
our life or you can think about why does
your boss act that way
they must have they must have unhappy
states of mind they must be unhappy they
must be angry and you can develop
compassion so your boss is then
transformed from someone who's just an
obstacle in your life to actually
someone who's helping you develop good
qualities now that's not to say that you
should be completely passive and just
you know sometimes it is appropriate to
say certain things if you
and of course but you still want to be
able to say something from the right
place from it from a good-hearted place
through having let go of the delusion